Как не допустить потерю контроля над
любой ситуацией вас кидали вас предавали
вас обманывали наверняка это случалось с
каждым из Вас практически нет человека с
которым бы это не происходило со мной
это происходило очень много раз и я на
этом терял очень много денег поэтому
если это видео про вас или у вас в жизни
были такие случаи или есть такие случаи
то обязательно досмотрите это видео до
конца и вы поймёте Как удержать ситуацию
под контролем благодаря своему
многолетнему опыту и и причём в основном
благодаря своему многолетнему
негативному опыту когда меня много
кидали обманывали предавали я выработал
такое понятие как критический фактор
контроля вы об этом Факторе не узнаете
нигде в интернете это тот фактор
контроля который я выработал именно
благодаря своему опыту и сегодня я хочу
с вами этим поделиться Что такое
критический фактор контроля критический
фактор контроля - это фактор который
гаранти
нам обеспечивает желательное нам
поведение других людей это очень важное
понимание сразу же приведу пример чтобы
было легче понять вот Представьте такую
ситуацию У вас есть ресторан Кафе
парихмакерская неважно что на таком
хорошем проходном месте Ну и вы начали
Этот бизнес провели ремонт и начали
раскручивать это место так вот вы когда
раскручивает это место Вдруг у вас может
быть у вас какое-то вкусное блюдо
какие-то вкусные блюда меню какие-то
фишки и вы начали к этому месту
привлекать Много людей много людей
начали приезжать к этому месту и
получилось так что вы раскрутили эту
точку и когда в вашем кафе ресторане там
или парихмахерской стоит большая очередь
куча людей желающих стать вашими
клиентами и вы поднимаете цену в этот
момент хозяин помещения вдруг решает
поднимать вашу арендную плату он
поднимает вашу арендную плату и Либо вы
начинаете платить ему больше и давать
большую часть вашей прибыли Либо вы
вынужден съехать с этого места а хозяин
помещения открывает на том же месте уже
на раскрученный месте а Свой ресторан
или кафе почему это произошло почему вас
кинули Почему ваши а многолетние труды
пошли прахом потому что вы не имели
критического фактора контроля над
ситуацией возьмём другой Пример например
вы ведёте свой бренд или вы работаете на
маркетплейсе и вы раскручивается свой
бренд вы
раскручивает ну вы знаете на
маркетплейсе тоже аккаунт раскручивается
и этот аккаунт в маркетплейсе тоже там в
рейтинге двигается и очень важно иметь
такой раскрученный аккаунт который в
первых там первой десятки первой Пятёрке
Ну короче на первой странице
маркетплейса так вот вы раскручивает
раскручивается и в какой-то момент у вас
похищают аккаунт и вы больше не
контролируйте ситуацию или возьмём
третий пример у каждого наверное в жизни
Бывало такое что в компании происходит
какая-то смута недовольство люди что-то
шепчутся между собой Там что-то мутят и
так далее и так далее и в какой-то
момент Люди перестают работать либо
отказываются работать либо начинают
массово уходить с вашей компанией и так
далее почему это происходит потому что
вы не имеете критического фактора
контроля если у вас в жизни было такое
то Ставьте лайк под видео и обязательно
прокомментируйте
напишите случалось ли с вами такое и
если случалось то просьба Описать как
это было или возьмём даже такую ситуацию
наверно которая известна всем вот
происходит какая-то забастовка люди
вышли на площадь и хавай шумм и это как
правило начинает разрастаться приходит
Ещё больше людей ещё больше людей и Как
властям справиться с этой ситуацией все
эти случаи объединяют одно понятие Это
наличие критического Фактора расскажу
вам как это работает в случае с кафе и
рестораном критическим фактором контроля
являлось право собственности на
помещение до тех пор пока вы не владеете
правом собственности на помещение у вас
нету критического фактора контроля и у
вас всё время существует риск того что
если вы сильно раскачает или раскрутить
эту точку то хозяин помещения либо
поднимет арендную плату либо выгонит вас
вторая ситуация если у вас есть аккаунты
то критическим фактором контроля для вас
будут являться пароли к этом аккаунтам
поэтому обязательно делайте
двухфакторную авторизацию обязательно
предусматривается способы восстановления
этого аккаунта и так далее Вы должны
понимать что если вы потеряете контроль
над своим аккаунтом то годы труда
пропадут А зря и критическим фактором
контроля у вас будет пароль в третьем
случае когда происходит смута в
коллективе А когда люди отказываются
работать или не хотят работать и так
далее или четвёртый случай возьмём когда
люди вышли на забастовку и так далее Что
делают власти в таких случаях в таких
случаях они в первую очередь изолируют
лидеров А В любой компании надо в первую
очередь собирать смутьянов и разбираться
с ними либо увольнять либо
Договариваться с неформальными лидерами
которые находятся в коллективе так вот
критическим фактором контроля В таких
ситуациях будет изоляция лидеров Как вы
видите критический фактор контроля - это
тот фактор который позволяет вам
гарантированно получать то то желаемое
поведение которое вы хотите от
окружающих Или давайте а рассмотрим
такую вещь вот если возьмём неживой мир
что будет являться критическим фактором
контроля например в езде на велосипеде
Вот вроди езда на велосипеде Что может
быть там что будет критическим фактором
контроля умение крутить педали умение
держать баланс либо умение сидеть что
критическим фактором контроля так вот в
езде на велосипеде например критическим
фактором контроля будет являться руль
потому что именно благодаря рулю вы
обеспечиваете баланс Вы наверное сами
пробовали делать Так когда вы заметили
Вы практически стоите на велосипеде и вы
баланс держите за счёт того что вы
крутите рулём второй момент велосипед
всегда приедет туда куда повернут руль
независимо от того кто крутит педали
какой скоростью он это делает поэтому
например в велосипеде критическим
фактором контроля будет руль смотрите в
любой вашей деятельности Вы должны
усвоить такую вещь что в любой вашей
деятельности есть один критический
фактор контроля и если вы например
работаете наёмным менеджером Подумайте у
вас тоже есть критический фактор
контроля благодаря которому ваш
работодатель вас не сможет уволить очень
часто кстати лоббисты и преступники
пользуются критическим фактором контроля
когда им нужно воздействовать на
каких-то политиков или нужно
воздействовать на каких-то представителе
администрации что они делают они
собирают Компромат и благодаря этому
Компромат Они получают гарантированное
желаемое поведение этих лиц то есть
критическим фактором контроля является
компромат на этих людей или приведу
другой достаточно такой пошлый пример но
он хорошо показывает или иллюстрирует
критический фактор контроля вот
предположим такая ситуация вот сидит э
напротив меня какой-нибудь человек я ему
говорю подай мне воду он может подать
воду а может не подать воду То есть
результат его поведение не гарантировано
теперь я говорю подай пожалуйста воду он
тоже может подать мне воду может не
подать но слово пожалуйста что сделало
оно только увеличивало увеличило мои
шансы того что что его поведение будет
желательным таким каким Я хочу что я
делаю дальше я говорю подай пожалуйста
мне воду Я за за это тебе заплачу там
100 долларов что я сделал Я увеличил
шансы того что он выполнит то что я хочу
То есть то что я получу желаемое
действие этим Вы каждый день практически
занимаетесь в компании Когда вы
работаете со своими сотрудниками Что вы
делаете некоторые просто говорят а
некоторые говорят вежливо или убеждают
некоторые подкрепляют ещё мотивации а
либо там каким-то стимулами а есть ещё
четвёртый тип Когда вы просто подходите
к этому человеку вот в данном случае о
котором я говорю берёте его За самое
больное место и говорите ему быстро
подал мне воду и вы знаете он
гарантированно подаст Вам воду потому
что вы держите его за критический фактор
контроля так вот у каждого человека у
каждого процесса у каждого бизнеса у
каждого вида деятельности есть
критический фактор контроля обязательно
находите его и держите его под своим
личным контролем до тех пор пока
критический фактор контроля находится у
вас вас никто не сможет кинуть ваша
прибыль не может
утечки люди в следующем видео Кстати я
расскажу и развенчал миф о том как стать
профессионалом за 100 или 10.000 часов
обязательно подпишись на мой канал и
следи за моими выпусками